-Welcome back, everybody.
We are hanging out with Ice-T,
right here!
Now...
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're known to say
the blunt truth,
so I thought you could
settle some of
the biggest and most important
debates of all time.
Are you ready to do this?
-Absolutely.
-Alright. It is time for
"Ice-T Settles It."
-♪ Ice-T settles it ♪
♪ Ice-T settles it ♪
-Okay. First up, blocking
or muting someone on Twitter?
-Mute them.
A lot of people get off
because they got blocked.
They -- Dummies write that off
as a badge --
You know what I call them.
-Yep.
-Dumb [bleep]
-Yeah, exactly, yeah.
-They get off
as a badge of honor.
"Ooh! I got blocked by Ice-T.
I'm important."
But if you mute them,
they don't know they're blocked,
and then they just yell off into
the Twitter void of nothingness.
They think
they're talking to you.
-Right?
-Yeah.
-Don't give them that --
-Hit that "mute" button
and let them yell into nothing,
and nobody gets to
hear them again.
Okay.
-I love it.
Number two, here we go.
How about this?
Slow Walkers or slow talkers?
-I hate slow talkers,
you know,
even though I rap slow.
But I don't have time --
I'm like,
"Speed it up, get to the point.
Like, what are you
talking about?"
I always do that with Coco.
I'm like...
"I know there's
a punch line coming.
Come on with it. Let's go."
Yeah, slow talkers drive me
bananas.
-I was behind, though,
a family this morning.
I was walking into work.
And it was -- They are the
slowest-walking family ever.
And I love that
they're a family,
and that's great and everything,
but there was like five of them.
And they really --
They were almost on the edge,
almost by the street.
They just had
the whole sidewalk blocked off.
-Yeah, I get that.
Well, I'm a slow walker, though.
You know, players --
we walk slow.
We in no rush.
-Oh, no. I walk like this.
-That's how you...
♪♪
-That's how I walk.
That's how I walk.
-Players walk like this.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We probably
walked by each other, yeah.
-Yeah, you don't want to
mess up your shoes.
You got to keep everything
together, you dig?
-How about this?
Should you reheat spaghetti?
-Yeah. Why not?
-I know.
I think it tastes --
-Why not?
I mean, it's good.
If it was good spaghetti.
If it was bad spaghetti,
it might turn into antimatter.
I don't know.
-You ever had fried spaghetti?
-You fry spaghetti?
-Check it out.
-No. Hey, you learn something
new on "Jimmy Fallon."
You know what I'm saying?
-Alright, how about this?
Ready?
PlayStation or Xbox?
-Oh, man, you trying to mess
with some of my sponsorships.
-No, no, no.
I would never do that.
-I mean, you know,
I actually have both systems.
-Yeah, I know.
-You know, they fight --
like, gamers --
But now they actually
have cross-platform playing,
where you can be on --
-Either one?
-Yeah.
So, I'm a gamer, but -- Yeah,
I had to have both of them
because some games exclusively
come out on the games first.
And I want them, so, you know --
One time, I told the people --
I said,
"I have two gaming consoles."
Like, "That's 'cause
you're rich."
It's not like it's two Bugattis.
You know what I'm saying?
-No, yeah, no. I understand.
-It's a damn gaming console.
-It's not like a
Bentley or Lamborghini, yeah.
-Take it easy, people.
-Take it easy.
"Call of Duty" or "Halo?"
-"Call of Duty."
-There you go.
-Only reason is 'cause
I'm not really a space guy,
even though I play "Destiny."
But I'm not into -- And, also,
I missed the
learning curve on "Halo."
"Call of Duty" is more real.
You run around with guns,
get it in.
-Okay.
Greatest rap album of all time.
-Ooh!
-That's difficult.
-I say "Paid in Full"
by Eric B. & Rakim.
-Wow! Wow! I love that.
-Yeah.
-Why that one?
-Because that was the
most influential album to me
when I was making my album.
I'll say
"Fear of a Black Planet"
with Public Enemy
would be a close second,
and then
"Straight Outta Compton," N.W.A,
would be the top three.
But each one of those albums
had a lot to do with influencing
me as an emcee.
But when I heard Rakim,
I had never heard
nobody rap like that.
And it was so many hits
on that album.
Get "Paid in Full,"
and you'll bang it
all the way to the house.
-Eric B. & Rakim. Love that.
-Yeah.
-Gucci or Chanel?
-Well, my daughter's
named Chanel.
This is a trick question.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Yeah, I got to go with Chanel.
She's probably gonna
watch this and think --
-Yeah. Hi, Chanel.
-But she likes Gucci, too.
You know, she -- We messed up.
I mean, we could have
named her anything.
We decided to name her something
that's going to break us
down the line, you know?
-Yeah, exactly, right?
-Because Coco -- So, it was
kind of play off of
Coco and Chanel.
So, yeah, that's what's up.
-How about this one then,
if she's watching?
"Dora" or "Peppa"?
-"Peppa Pig."
-Alright.
-Straight up, "Peppa Pig."
-Wow!
-"Peppa Pig" has Chanel
talking like she's British.
[ Laughter ]
-[ British accent ]
"Muddy puddles."
Yeah, "muddy puddles."
-"Muddy puddles."
-[ Normal voice ]
Yeah, yeah. "Ready, steady.
Ready, steady."
I'm like,
"It's 'ready, set, go.'"
"No, no, Daddy.
It's ready, steady, go."
-Iced tea --
sweetened or unsweetened?
-Who drinks
unsweetened iced tea?
That's some white people [bleep]
[ Laughter, applause ]
-I was going to say me.
I was going to say me.
"Can I get unsweetened, please?
♪♪
I want unsweetened."
-Black people has real --
We drink sweetness.
We drink Kool-Aid.
We drink things that taste good.
You know?
And tea is not the place to go
to get healthy anyway.
I mean, you can do green tea,
I get it, if that's your thing.
But unsweetened tea --
that's nasty.
-Okay, here we go.
Last one, law or order?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, law is --
Law would be the court, I guess.
-Yep.
-So it's mother[bleep]
order, cuz, come on.
-Yeah, that's what I'm
talking about.
Come on, that is Ice-T!
My thanks to Ice-T.
"Law & Order: SVU" returns with
new episodes April 28th.
We'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show."